movie opens with home video footage of a
family celebration cliche also Brian
dreams and VHS I wonder if the store
sells any laptops or plasma white
screens you know there it is Wow there
was a six-minute pause between these two
comments but thankfully the director
dropped it out in post in their attempt
to make this guy look like a devoted
father filmmakers go too far and end up
slipping into creepy dad territory when
in your life when getting together with
three other bros to have a guys night
did three of the guys meet up ahead of
time and travel together to the host
bros house hey you remember when we're
in Beirut after the chief disappeared
movie steals the casual unexplained
battle reference to foreign country that
starts with a B thing from the Avengers
twenty-five hundred bucks just for
taking some pop diva to him from her
concert for one short because four is
needed for a quorum of past their prime
spy guys doing the work laid off mall
cops should be doing see all three of
these grown Asperger's rogue together
there is no way his daughter could tell
what that song was over the phone also
this arena has signs that are about as
helpful as a compass popstar assassin
coincidentally chooses the one night
Brian is doing a security gig for his
murder attempts so that we can get more
evidence of badassery also what was this
guy's plan he was somehow gonna get past
security and stab a pop star to death 20
million records selling pop star pays
security in cash fine dining lunch spot
has one condiment on the table mustard
because you're under 18 you name my
information to leave the country doesn't
Kim's mom have full custody why would
they need her dad's signature for
anything I don't think a 17 year old
should be traveling alone oh geez it is
taking a long time for someone to get
taken hey Kimmy there's something else
horrible father who was horrible the
science that after disappointing his
daughter now is the time to bring up
singing lessons you sacrificed our
marriage in the service of the country
you made a mess of your life in the
service of your country
he just sacrificed just a little this
one time for your own daughter I think
this is literally the worst argument
I've ever heard
Liam Neeson's Academy Award submission
clip for this film consisted entirely of
this coffee sip you're just
first Dark Phoenix is addicted darkman
this is a great drive by transition shop
but they are four lanes over from their
exit here's a map to your daughter's
lives plot it in plain view really who
does this unless it's so her father
could see it later and get pissed and
add to the drama what is this
it's u2's European tour days all the
kids do you - Kim really are you like
negative four years old when Joshua tree
came out there is no parking in the
loading and unloading zone apparently
there are airports where you can just
back through a metal detector and there
are no TSA people waiting for you on the
other side also the TSA does emit kim
remove her gaudy rhinestone jacket even
sex trade recruiter waits for potential
targets at a taxi stand also and
wondering what the success rate is or
what the quota for recruiter is when
manning a taxi stand if you get one girl
in two weeks is that a success or do
they want girls every day and they're
telling this guy there's always money in
the taxi stand i mean this can't work
that much right and here's the password
to my email address and the PIN number
for my bank card and here's the schedule
of all the times we'll be lying naked in
the room with the curtains open how do
they drag two young women down five
floors into broad daylight without being
seen earlier we saw this guy Peter
inviting them to a party and later we
see this girl saying she was kidnapped
going to a party so why take the risk
during the day when almost everyone in
Paris could walk by and see you also
these kidnappers work fucking fast she's
still dancing to that first song she
started playing thirty seconds after
saying goodbye to Peter and walking into
the apartment
Paris is a big-ass city are there
kidnappers on every corner just waiting
for work this bad guy can drag an entire
human out from underneath the bed
without crouching or bending over
kidnappers have no use for blindfolds
and gags if you let my daughter go now
that'll be the end of it oh okay hey
guys the guy on the other end of this
line says he'll let us go if we don't
take his daughter I think that's a fair
deal right I will look for you
I will find you and I will kill you Liam
Neeson is only threatening to kill
someone in the scene
also why is Brian speaking English to
this guy he hasn't heard anything but
Albanian so far this whole badass speech
could fall upon ears who think he's
ordering takeout for God's sake I got a
call ha ha ha you wish dude you're the
one who called to tell me a plane to
Paris to win an hour ago will have to go
through some back channels but I think
we have a time-traveling plane on
standby since this is the only on the
plane footage we get to see I have no
choice but to assume Brian spent the
entire 12-hour flight to Paris listening
to this audio over and over again 2
baguettes sticking out of the grocery
bag to look extra French also why did he
buy so much Wow somebody saw the Bourne
Identity couldn't Brian have just walked
down the hall and picked a lock to get
into the apartment and why would the
kidnappers lock the place after trashing
it good manners
Brian remembers Kim's abduction the way
it should have been with the guy
crouching to drag her from under the bed
what is he gonna send that to the lab
for the record it's never even mentioned
again just a hair in a bag in his pocket
during the rest of the shit you see
happen a magical process button helping
photographers at European kiosks since
2005 Brian thinks tackling a guy in a
taxicab at an airport will arouse any
suspicion at all and the driver will
just go wherever two fighting guys want
to go sure they just stumble and stand
in the street rather than going to the
sidewalk driver prefers to honk his horn
rather than slowing down and not killing
someone also Liam Neeson didn't kill
anyone in this scene and guessing in the
French police don't really give a damn
about the guy that just caused the
collision who traffic jam and fatality
discount French Kevin Spacey talking
about Cuba that same asshole you honor
one of them says the sausage get him hot
pepper now they're cooking about
football
Ronnie's on the phone these guys cover
an incredible range of topics in 30
seconds Brian just happens to find his
daughter's jacket with another girl
after looking in two rooms
it takes 47 minutes and 21 seconds for
Liam Neeson to kill someone in this
movie without knowing a damn thing about
what Brian looks like these guys start
shooting at someone who has his back
turned and his
a way to identify apparently any person
can just drive onto this legal sex
trafficking construction site without so
much as a password there are literally
hundreds of directions this guy could
have driven in the middle of the
construction site and he decides to go
through flames Bryan rammed this Jeep
into two pickup trucks and all it needs
is a carwash indestructible Jeep is
indestructible stealing cars is okay as
long as something bad has happened to
you I guess because Bryan is this form
of government badass we shouldn't ask
where he got all this medical even
though he changed cars that didn't have
anything other than the girl with him
just seconds ago in the world of Bryan
Mills it pays to be the one prostitute
in the entire brothel that had his
daughter's jacket because this one cool
down I guess that clears up the question
of whether French computer operators
also annoyingly narrate their own work
I'm walking talking through an O via
phone and vice versa
this setup would have made for the worst
reception ever and this girl remembered
an awful lot about this random drive to
a house and being drugged for a couple
days well okay that checks out a friend
gave this to me it's Albanian you mind
translating it good luck
why did Bryan need the translator guy to
bring him in Albanian English dictionary
again all he uses it for words to write
two whole words down good and luck and
he paid this translator guy for ten
hours of work when he needed him for
only two minutes couldn't the translator
guy I've written down those two words
bubi conveniently kills Amanda so that
Bryan doesn't have to save her and look
after her for the rest of the movie
French guy carrying a French baguette
cliche this seems to be both a dangerous
place to keep a gun and an inconvenient
one if you happen to need it in a pitch
Bryan figured John clonk kept his secret
gun under the sink of course the last
thing you'll say before I make your
children orphans as the bullet I put
between our eyes killing an innocent
person is okay as long as something
really bad has happened to you okay was
like fifty pages of the script Bryan
walks down hallway with
indistinguishable doors Bryan Bailey
gets to the virgin option in time to see
his daughter go up for sale was Hitler
unavailable for the scene yr old Asian
men and Middle Easterners the only evil
bidders after killing all those people
highly-trained badass forgets that he
left a trail of dead guys that might
cause alarm this is a very unique
business with a very unique clientele
please define very unique the pipes
typically hang from weak brackets
screwed to the ceiling well I guess the
ones expected to keep Leonie
in captivity do it only now occurred to
this guy to whip out his gun after Brian
just sculpt this entire lousy crew would
you please go see which part of the word
quietly they did not understand st.
Claire employees of grammar nazi' to
enforce word violations on his sex
trafficking crew it was all business it
wasn't personal this is a ridiculously
stupid line but I guess anything goes to
set up Liam Neeson grumbling it was
personal to me before he caps this guy
is he the t1000 now there was really no
reason for this dude to look back
through the window like this but good
thing he did it because he saw the
clumsiest spotted through a window shot
in movie history buying his soul equal
his foot shot skill he's a badass but
like many heroes he's had an awful lot
of help from hunting with terrible aim
this guy's giant head is not suited for
standoffs such as this no tricky
extradition problems for a guy that
murdered at least 10 people on French
soil hi meaningless plot point resolved
in the final seconds of film after being
kidnapped sold into sexual slavery and
barely nearly raped by a fat dude on a
boat Kimi still decides to pursue a
lifetime of spotlight and stalkers
you I will find you and I will kill you
football practice man that's a real
shame when folks be throwing away a
perfectly good white boy like that I'm
Spartacus I'm Spartacus
ocular chilled frenzy filled prosity
Kilimanjaro
oh yes slight meal
reading a short while back we were
contacted by a company called naturebox
about the possibility of doing an ad now
I need a lot of energy and protein for
sitting so I definitely snack a lot but
and we are artists we can't just go
around doing ads for any old company so
we told them hey we only do ads for
products we actually use phoney
integrity cliche and you know what those
guys are clever they sent me a box of
their stuff so I was like now I have to
try it and you know what once I did then
I was like oh now I have to do the ad
because I've used the product cinemasins
is gullible naturebox is this wonderland
for snack fiends sending to your door
boxes of delicious natural tasty treats
no high fructose corn syrup none of that
trans fat garbage just snacks cheddar
pretzels nuts and almonds granola
freakin plantain chips looking to eat
healthier snacks trying to eat better in
general just love the fucking shit out
of granola naturebox has your back and
just for our viewers they have a 50% off
special on your first order at nature
box Commons oh and they ship for free
delicious add is not edible so go to
nature box calm